Mischa Barton is determined to shine on
Dancing with the Stars ultimately I'm
not a quitter
since joining the dancing competition
show it hasn't exactly been an easy ride
for the actress I think my confidence
was knocked a little bit as well because
it was Tucker it was tough this week but
like I think we'll get there first she
struggled with the tango and on Monday
her cha-cha showed improvement but still
didn't impress the judges
there was a lot of cha-cha-cha there it
just didn't fit to the music our first
week was very stressful so then we got
sick and we both ended up Blake you know
having to deal with that and learning
this um this cha chaan just like I think
it's more show day like just being
preparing yourself mentally and a good
way for it because even if we do it well
somewhere else we need to be doing it
well out there on the dance floor so
true the 30 year old told et she's
grateful for all the love she's received
especially from her former OC co-star
rachel Bilson who posted this supportive
Instagram pic last week despite the
challenges that lie ahead barton says
she's in it to win it ultimately I'm not
a quitter
so you know we'll just like keep our and
groove by figuring out like our rhythm
and get get these dances